[Music]
[Music]
my name is Paul Penfield I'm the MIT
host of this symposium and I'm pleased
to welcome you all to MIT I would say
first of all I'd like to make sure that
you all realized that the brains behind
this whole outfit is this gentleman
standing to your right here that's Andy
Van Damme and you'll have plenty of
chance to hear him and see him in action
because he's going to be the emcee for
the for the whole affair and I want to
make sure that you realize that if
there's any success associated with this
symposium it's all due to him and if
there are any failures it's probably
because the local arrangements have not
been done well and that was my province
okay I will alert you to the fact that
restrooms are located by the door where
you came in and just in case you didn't
notice it this is always a question that
people ask here I'd also like to tell
you that the coffee breaks and the lunch
are both held upstairs and if you go
back through the corridor that you use
to get to this room you will find a set
of stairways which will lead you
upstairs to where the coffee will be
served during the coffee break and the
lunch will be served at noontime the
reception this afternoon is in the lobby
of a very appropriate building it's the
bush building at MIT you will get
directions on how to get there at the
time and there's also a little map in
your packet that shows how to get there
and there will be a whole group of
people that will go over all MAS - -
they're now at the banquet the banquet
will be held at the Hyatt which is a
hotel which is down that away and you
can also follow the whole group from the
reception to get there I don't think
you'll have any problem and it's all
within walking distance let me mention
that this this event is being
transmitted
three different ways for those of you
who are interested the local audience
probably is not but those of you who are
listening to my voice out there
somewhere out in never-never land I'd
mentioned that this is being broadcast
on the MIT cable channel nine it is also
being broadcast by the multicast
backbone system of the internet called M
bone and M bone is very good in
supplying good audio and maybe some
video in addition the slides as used by
the various speakers are available in
real time on the world wide web and
those of you who are listening right now
can turn on a web browser and access a
following URL the URL is known as HTTP
colon slash slash www - Evi 80 /b u sh /
and somewhere i should have a foil which
shows that but unfortunately the foil
master disappeared on us oh well let's
get it off where's the foil itself
it's the third foil
okay those of you in TV land can now
copy that down and this should also be
the foil which is shown on the worldwide
web without saying anything more about
this I'd like to turn the proceedings
over to Andy Van Dam who will give a
little introduction including something
about the life of Bush himself and roll'
Aki and will then introduce another
speaker Paul Kuhn Andy thanks very much
Paul good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this wonderful celebration I
would like to start off by thanking the
folks who made all this happen and first
and foremost Lisa Manik offski from
Brown University and the center for
graphics and scientific visualization
she has been this symposium can we have
lights on her for a moment please
[Applause]
she has eaten drinkin and slept the
symposium for the last few months and
she will also be behind the registration
desk and any logistics questions you may
ask her about second of all the
gentleman who looks like you do not want
to mess with him over there is dr.
Robert McDermott from Utah AV specialist
extraordinaire as well as a computer
graphics researcher and he is our
producer and you do what he says this is
especially true for us speakers he and
his sidekick Jim rose from Utah have
been working on this for a very long
time and mostly with their colleagues
from the local institution Larry
Gallagher can we see you Larry or is he
in the back room I assume most of these
people are hard at work making the
conference happen so we'll just give him
around after I finished Scott dines who
was pressed into service relatively
recently to learn all about mbone and is
now a certified mbone guru and at
moriarity who has been doing yeomen
service on all aspects of systems
computers and AV local folks who've done
a heroic service let's have a hand for
them
[Applause]
David clop Hawk from Brown has been
helping out with producing all aspects
of the symposium slides various details
of Av and organizing a group of student
and staff volunteers from both Brown and
MIT thank you very much folks second
category of people without whom we
wouldn't be here are the sponsors who
have contributed money to make this
happen National Science Foundation Apple
Microsoft the center the individual home
institutions and two companies who
kindly lend us the gear that we will be
using today thanks now what I'd like to
do to set the stage a little bit is to
tell you how this celebration came about
and I want to give all appropriate
credit to the folks who actually had the
idea to whit Greg Lloyd Steve de Rose
and Chris Newsom former students of mine
well indoctrinated in hypertext and
hyper media systems in the case of Greg
going back to the 60s and these folks
are now employees of electronic book
technologies they formed a Reading Club
and read all through the literature and
came to my office one Saturday and said
look do you realize it's 50 years ago
that as we may think came out we should
do something we cannot leave this the
occasion go unmarked and I said you're
right that's a very good idea so then
they said alright fine why don't you
execute this wonderful idea and so they
can get the credit for having had it and
the rest of us were left to implement
now my concept of what we ought to do to
mark this is not to have a media circus
but instead to have a small research
symposium which in German academic life
last century was called a Festschrift
fest in the sense of festivity and
shrift in the sense of something written
down well different media today but you
get the idea
essentially you honor an outstanding
researcher by having a research
symposium in his or her honor populated
by the best folks in that field and a
lot
former students typically so my concept
for this was let's put on the only thing
we can do a posthumous Festschrift
and honor him by having pioneering
researchers speak many of whom have been
influenced by as we may think we found
great enthusiasm on the part of dr. Paul
Penn field and he threw himself into
this project with heart and soul and
many late night hours particularly to
work up this companion piece of software
that he modestly told us about in just a
moment I'm proud to say that all of the
speakers I invited accepted I think
that's pretty good testament to the
magic of the bush name and the
contribution now this event I want to
give you some caveats about what this
event is and is not it is specifically
focused on highlighting as we may think
not the many other hugely important
aspects of Bush's amazing career and his
great impact on our society to do
justice to Bush the man and all his
contributions would require a set of
specialized symposia some technical some
social political and economic and
philosophical and that work remains to
be done by another group now this
symposium even in its narrow focus is in
no way meant to be either comprehensive
or representative there isn't time or
room I picked a handful of true computer
pioneers who have helped to define our
field and they will speak to various
aspects of the as we may think mimics
vocoder vision and I preferred longer
more thoughtful in-depth talks to a
larger number of shorter talks matter of
taste what I want to do now having told
you a little bit about the genesis of
this is to do a very cursory job
reintroducing you to Bush the man and
his manifold contributions what I'd like
to do before the chronology is to roll a
couple of minutes of videotape which
Paul has lent us can I block that Robert
thank you
[Applause]
dr. Vannevar Bush is one of America's
more important citizens now in his 66th
year this son of the Universalist
minister has served the government for
various periods over a period of about
40 years and the last four presidents
have called him fan dr. Bush has been
called the Dean of American scientists
one of the great mathematicians
electrical engineers and research
administrators of our time during World
War two he was the guiding spirit and
the driving force of America's
achievements in the physical and medical
sciences
he was the research boss of the Atomic
Scientists the first civilian scientist
to sit with our highest war council dr.
Bush served many years as vice president
of MIT the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology and recently he retired as
president of the Carnegie Institution of
Washington today dr. and mrs. Bush live
in this brand-new house that they
recently finished building it's on a
wooded hilltop a half hour drive west of
Boston in Belmont Massachusetts good
evening dr. Boyce well good evening ed
how are you tonight well indeed thank
you well sir I've known you a number of
years and last week I managed to
mispronounce van Eber and I apologize
well you've got plenty of company there
and most everyone mispronounces it I
think the record that held by one
postmaster who managed to pronounce it
before different ways in the course of
one of you dr. Bush you built electric
brains and atomic bombs how does that
compare with the experience of building
a new house well building a house is a
much more pleasure sorry so now you know
that we've all been mispronouncing it
all these years I'm told it's originally
a Dutch name but being Dutch I don't
necessarily buy that okay slide again
please there is no way to do justice in
just a few slides to this truly
remarkable
career so I just took a few of the
highlights I may have missed some other
highlights you'll notice his life in a
khadeem was all in the northeast he
spent a huge part of it at MIT and
started working in the 20s already on
what we now think of as an analog
computer the differential analyzer many
many versions of it including into World
War two the Rockefeller differential
analyzer which was partially electronic
and partially mechanical and was a huge
room full of numerical calculation
equipment he was appointed vice
president of MIT in the first Dean of
the School of Engineering as Paul
Penfield reminded me patented the
differential analyzer and then started
working on the device that concerns us
most here today the microfilm based
rapid selector which was an information
storage and especially retrieval
mechanism he then went to Washington he
had many positions in Washington and it
was probably the most single most
influential scientist and engineer
during the war years throwing himself
into the war effort on a number of
fronts what is particularly important to
us is this appointment to the office of
scientific research and development and
the fact that he was President Roosevelt
science advisor and these various
appointments made him a central figure
in the development of nuclear fission
and indeed he was the one who kicked off
the Manhattan Project in 45 as we know
as we may think appeared it was based on
more than a decade of cogitation in this
area so he was basically summarizing
what he had been thinking and working on
for a very long time then very important
to our profession as a whole indeed to
science as a whole President Roosevelt
asked dr. Bush to think about what we
could learn from World War two and to
see how we could apply the enormous
progress in science and engineering to
the civilian sector not just to war he
wrote science the endless frontier which
led effectively via one of its
recommendations to the formation of the
science foundation
this is what the report looks like we
have a copy of it here if any of you
would like to browse and this is one of
the wonderful quotes from there still as
relevant today as when he wrote it the
pioneer spirit is still vigorous within
this nation science offers a largely
unexplored hinterland for the Pioneer
who has the tools to I can't quite read
it from here for this task the rewards
of such exploration both for the nation
and the individual are great scientific
progress is one essential key in our
security as a nation to our better
health to more jobs to a better standard
of living and to our cultural progress
powerful words he was appointed chairman
of yet another national military
establishment board and it's important
to remember that he was a civilian and
it was most unusual for a civilian to
hold all these high positions
influencing the course of the military
directly another offshoot of his
interest in microfilm and recording and
distributing things photographically is
that he founded and became chairman of
the graphics arts Research which
developed the photon photo typesetter
then he became a member of the National
Science Foundation Advisory Committee
chairman of the MIT corporation and
honorary chairman of the MIT corporation
for many years here are some of his
selected publications and it's
interesting to note how widely he wrote
he didn't just write about science or
science policy he also wrote about
multiple other things somewhat related
in books like this a collection of
essays where for example he has multiple
chapters devoted to his musings on the
art and science of management all my
life which has now lasted something
under 100 years I've observed managers
in action in government and universities
and in industry and I've puzzled over
what made them tick I'm far from the end
of the puzzle for no man can ever fully
understand another even a close friend
but we can probe a bit toward the
essence of the good the
great managers success the world is so
short on good managers that it is
certainly worth a try and he has many
interesting observations about what
makes for a good manager the list of
honours is phenomenal and we decided to
stick to just one page here they are I'm
not going to read them to you you notice
that they include both the Order of the
British Empire and presidential medals
presented by presidents I can't think of
anyone more honored for a multitude of
activities engineering science and
policymaking than Vannevar Bush and
another partial reflection of how he was
appreciated a list of his honorary
degrees the thing that I want to do next
having said just the briefest outline of
his life and times is to give my own
spin on Memex and Bush's thinking in
context so I'm going to talk for a few
minutes about historical antecedents
although we might like to think that
we're only now entering or well into the
Information Age the acquisition and
management of information has of course
been central to human society since
prehistoric times language is an
invention it is a technology for
organizing and transmitting information
writing in particular transform the
ability of societies to record and
transmit culture and information more
specifically the phone attic alphabet
was an immense improvement on its
syllabic and idea graphic predecessors
other major achievements which we tend
to take for granted but we shouldn't
because they are so hugely important in
our successful ability to deal with
information the invention of the page of
punctuation of spacing between words of
capitalization tables of contents
indices alphabetic sorting and so on
these were inventions and they took time
to take root and they've made a
qualitative and quantitative difference
in our productivity now hypertext as a
very particular style of writing
non-sequential writing as Ted defined it
deals with things like marginalia and
cross-references and see also
now hypertextual techniques make an
appearance very early on in the history
of writing and have evolved to be a
major feature of our literacy in the
largest sense I just want to illustrate
with a couple of things that I find
fascinating this is a 16th century King
James epistle of Apostle Paul to the
Romans and you will see that there is
not just the main text but little
superscripts and lots of marginalia at
which itself has additional cross
references and this helped you
understand the Bible the writings in
their cultural historical and religious
contests now this 16th century
manuscript hardly started this
technology and it wasn't obvious to the
average reader on exactly how it was to
be used as a tool so the printer felt it
necessary to instruct the reader on how
to deal with this and wrote what I
consider to be one of the first users
manual it says diligent reader
dear Christian reader to the intent thou
mightest better enjoyed the benefit of
these I can't read it from here I
apologize
he lays out the typographic conventions
and exactly how you are to wind your way
through this because not everybody who
picked up this manuscript was familiar
with other things like it like the
Talmud which for many centuries had made
it a point of having annotation be the
point of the discourse so the center is
the primary text and then we have
generations of commentary and commentary
upon commentary with all their cross
references scattered typographically
about the page and that too is a
convention that has to be learned
well the Talmud didn't invent marginalia
either we can go much further back this
manuscript from poems by BA Kalidas i'm
mispronouncing no doubt is there's a
papyrus scroll that dates roughly from
three the 3rd century AD but the poet
actually wrote it three centuries bc and
fortunately the the written version of
this which we cannot tell how faithful
it was to the original was found along
with other scrolls in the sands of the
egyptian desert and we're preserved for
edification and pleasure so here's an
example of that you will notice in the
second column I forgot to bring the
laser pointer but you can see in the
second column there are two kinds of
things sticking off slightly to the left
a marginal note and then there is some
kind of little glyph at the bottom that
is probably some kind of coded reference
so thank you
the man who is never unprepared right
there and right there
thanks well not surprisingly inventors
at least as far back as the Renaissance
imagined mechanical devices to support
hypertextual readings I want to show you
one absolutely stunning woodcut from an
engineer from the 16th century
rahmel II who invented effectively a
rotating bookcase in which you could
have pages opened and cross-references
to other pages and then just by turning
a wheel which was a cogged levered piece
of machinery
get yourself to the appropriate place
this was imitated by Chinese and I have
a Louisville lovely drawing of a Chinese
temple that I can show you later
which shows one of these machines in it
in symbolic form and then we actually
have some ruins that people photographed
from a temple from I think 6th century
AD where a device like this was
apparently built so mechanical aids have
been around for a long time more
recently researchers such as Michael
Buckland who studied the the history of
information technology and W Boyd
Raymond have been recovering for our
attention neglected 19th and 20th
century thinkers to i'll mentioned today
paul otlet a belgian who lived from 1868
to 1944 and Emanuel Goldberg a Russian
from 1881 to 1970 both of whom created
information management systems in the
early 20th century outlet for instance
implemented a hypertext like system with
analog means and imagined multimedia
document management systems that would
work with linked microfilm and
telecommunications based on a variant of
the duodecimal called called a universal
Decimal Classification and probably the
first book on information science was
prepped a document a Co written in 1934
Goldberg who became the first managing
director of size icon in Germany
demonstrated and later patented a
prototype of a microfilm selector much
like Memex
using a photoelectric cell the first
functioning electric electronic document
retrieval system in 1932 his patent was
in fact prior art for Bush's attempt to
patent the rapid selector he was
unfortunately driven out by the Nazis
first went to Paris then to Israel where
he died these ingenious systems were in
some respects similar to Bush's in some
respects different I really hope you
will get a chance to look at the work of
these earlier thinkers and thank folks
who brought these citations to to my
attention they're absolutely fascinating
but our perspective today is not with
Bush's predecessors but with Bush and
his followers and for introducing you to
that theme of our conference I'd like to
introduce you to my friend and colleague
Paul Khan who is going to tell us a
little bit about bush and the Memex Paul
is one of the two official in quotes
memik historians by virtue of having
written the book that you all know about
Memex - hypertext and I in academic
press 1991 from mx2 hypertext by nice
and Kahn he got a BS in English from
Kenyon he was a director at the
Institute for research and information
science at Brown University that I
helped start in the early 80s and after
iris folded he became president of
dynamic diagrams where he still is under
his direction this summer
Ian Adelman did a Memex visualization
using macro media director and that is
one of the things that Paul will show us
Paul would you come on stage please
can I get the slides what I'm gonna do
is go over some visual material Andy has
shown you a timeline with some of the
names and some of the dates I'm going to
show you some pictures that correspond
to a number of the machines that he's
already already discussed this is
Vannevar bush 1912 he's a graduate
student at Tufts University in Medford
Massachusetts and this is his first
invention this machine was called the
profile tracer it was a machine for
doing surveying of land next slide
please
oh I got him I make the next slide sorry
this machine would actually draw out the
profile of the land that you ran it
across and the reason that it did that
was a mechanism that involved a wheel
integrator that would actually plot on
paper and it was this basic technique or
technology that became the became the
starting point for many of the analog
computers that Bush then later developed
at MIT with his graduate students the
first really successful one was called
the product integral this is from 1925
and was developed at MIT between 25 and
28 this machine which was both
electrical and mechanical there's an
electric motor by his hand there was
capable of solving second-order
differential equations and was awarded a
number of engineering prizes the the
mechanism behind this and it could get
quite large when you wanted to solve
fairly large second-order differential
equations that's that's van in the front
of the line there the mechanism behind
this became the basis for what was then
developed around 1928 through the mid
30s the differential analyzer which was
a little bit larger and the differential
analyzer was capable of running very
complex differential equations and
people literally came from all over the
world
to MIT to solve their differential
equations on this machine and there were
a number of machines built in Europe
imitating this machine to solve an
equation you actually had to set up all
of the wheels and the rods to model the
equation and then you ran it and it
would solve the equation by plotting it
out in curves on these readouts this is
Sam Caldwell in the foreground and van
Busche behind him looking at a family of
curves this photo is from around 1932 so
this technology was very promising and
won the many awards and funding from a
number of agencies and this was really
the main line of research that Bush was
known for before he went to Washington
and became a major public figure the the
line of research here at MIT culminated
in the largest of these machines the
Rockefeller differential analyzer that's
what you see in this photograph and just
to get a sense of scope here this
machine weighed about 100 tons had 2000
vacuum tubes a few thousand relays and a
hundred and 50 motors this machine was
built in 42 and was used for calculating
ballistics tables during the war it was
made public in 45 and by the time it was
shut down in 1950 it was the last of the
analog machines it was quite clear by
the late 40s that this was just not a
particularly fruitful line of research
once digital computers began to be
developed in the in the mid and late 40s
but what really concerns us is another
line of research that was going on in
parallel with this around 1937 here at
MIT in one of the labs Bush was
supervising a project for building a
microfilm rapid selector and
unfortunately there are no photographs
or actual drawings of this machine but
this schematic which was put together by
Tom bag at the one of the national
research institutes is the the best
thing we've got and what's going on here
is that you had a roll of 35 millimeter
film
figure out what to press here we go
there was a roll of 35 millimeter film
and that film on each frame of the
standard movie film had basically a
double frame one frame was a piece of
microfilm with a picture of a page and
the rest of that film was a mask of dots
that film could be run fairly rapidly
through a transport mechanism there were
about 120,000 frames on the roll and you
could run that roll through the machine
in about two minutes there was a set of
photo relays over here that was running
light through the mass and the strobe
which had been developed by dr. Edgerton
here at MIT was being used to fire off a
second recording camera when the mask
actually matched the dot pattern on the
film and so it would rerecord individual
frames on a second roll of film you
could run you could develop a mask that
matched a particular piece of
information you wanted to retrieve off
the film would run through the entire
film rerecord only those frames that
contained the information you were
looking for and then you had a second
microfilm that contained those selected
pages this is the technology that was
being developed in Bush's lab and this
as far as we can tell is the technology
that was behind the article that he was
writing at the time the first manuscript
that we found here at the MIT archives
Jim nice and I when we were working on
this of what became as we may think was
entitled mechanization in the record and
it dates from around 1938 before Bush
left MIT and went to Washington this
idea of having microfilm rapid selectors
continued to be developed in the 50s and
the 60s this is a microfilm rapid
selector film from one that was done at
the ER a in Washington and this was done
under CIA sponsorship at Yale University
in the 1960s as you see that the dot
patterns got more complex the problem
with these machines was that they didn't
work they were really a very nice idea
but that the technology couldn't move
the film fast enough or or record the
position of things accurately enough to
be practical but they kept building them
for about 20 years and they kept getting
larger this is actually a picture of the
rapid selector from
Yale University one of the last ones
built around 1962 Busch was also working
on a few other things that he patented
one of them is the justifying typewriter
I don't know how many people realize
that he held the patent on that one and
the justifying typewriter which is what
he and Sam Caldwell are standing in
front of over here also became part of
the mechanism for the early photon photo
typesetter he was basically hooking up
electronic relays and photographing
things on film that was behind the photo
typesetter as well now the article which
finally appeared in 45 just days after
the atomic bombing in Japan attracted a
lot of people's attention and it was
then reprinted in Life magazine which is
the article that you've got in your
packet here the illustrations appeared
in the in the time reprint the one that
you've got and these illustrations were
done by a technical illustrator by the
name of Alfred Cryme who had been
working at Sperry Rand in New York and
was called by the editors at Life and
asked if he would please illustrate this
article because when it originally
appeared and in the Atlantic Monthly of
course there were no pictures and Life
magazine really liked to have pictures
so what Cryme did was he read the
article and that's really all he had to
go on and he came up with these drawings
such as this one which is the MINIX and
his notion of what it looked like was
based on the text as well as the fact
that he'd been doing a lot of technical
illustrating on different types of
machines that Sperry had been building
and he sent the illustrations to Bush
for approval and Bush said yep that's
okay there was really no more detail to
it than that now and the and II ran one
videotape there are two interviews that
are in the MIT archives that one would
Edward R Morrow and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to run a little tiny piece
of another one both of them are from the
60s this one is from 1964 from the MIT
science reporter you'll see John Fitch
MIT science reporter at the beginning
and then a little bit of Bush this is
the only place where we found in the
record that Bush publicly talks about
anything that you might imagine was
related to mimics other than the printed
articles no one ever asked him about
this then whenever interviewed in
and certainly in any of the any of the
TV interviews that were done later
everyone was very concerned about what
he thought at the atomic bomb but what
he thought about mimics was never
brought up but this at least comes close
if you could roll the videotape please I
think one position that I talked to
marveled at it more because it was as
though it had finally unlocked the real
secret that got him down to the basic
ascension but all the ways of biology
that are wrong subtlety was going on
we're getting a whole new understanding
the physiology then what's being done on
the way in which the nerves operate is
fascinating and the relations the
resemblances between the brains
operations and the operations of a
modern analytical machine there's a
fascinating aspect of speaking of
analytical machines this is something
that you pioneered in what do you think
about the present-day computer and
perhaps its role in our future well you
sort of another goal that there was so
much happening in the world but it'd
probably be impossible to understand it
or keep up with it well that would be
true if it wasn't for the fact that we
have far better means of understanding
that we used to have so I've got a media
a communication far better ways of
presenting things including the little
job that you and I are doing now and
that's helping a great deal but as time
goes on the analytical machine which
will supplement a man's thinking methods
which will think for it yeah we'll have
as great an effect on his grasp of the
world and his access to data and so on
his manipulation of well that was great
an effect in that way as the invention
of the machine way back took the load
off of men by giving them mechanical
power instead of the power of their
muscles do you see no dangers in the
increasing reliance on the machine to
think for us no I don't see any once in
a while somebody that wants to write for
spectacular
purposes we'll talk about a race of
self-reproducing machines take over
civilization banish humanity like the
old Frankenstein story well we still
believe in fairy tale for true they're
amusing but that's all
of course second Thank You Anne what I'm
gonna do to finish up is I'm going to
run an animation that we created this
summer my colleague Jim nice so
unfortunately can't be here today who
worked on the book with me it makes the
very succinct point that the mimics
while it was never built was a form of
speculative and imaginative engineering
which clearly has inspired many of us
and with that in mind we did a little
speculative and imaginative animation to
run this was created largely by Ian
Adelman who at the time was a student
Industrial Design at Rhode Island School
of Design and now is employed by
Microsoft Corporation out in Redmond
and the relations the resemblances
between the brains operations and the
operations of a modern analytical
machine there's a fascinating aspect of
[Applause]
this was our model of the Memex and this
animation allows you to either listen to
a recreation of the scenario from the
article or simply go in and point and
explore they explore the animation we'll
run through this little condensed
section of the Turkish boa scenario
which is found at the end of the article
first
I think we lost the audio first he runs
through an encyclopedia finds an
interesting but sketchy article and
leaves it projected next in a history he
finds another pertinent item and ties
the two together thus he goes building a
trail of many items occasionally he
inserts a comment of his own either
linking it into the main trail or
joining it by a side trail to a
particular item his trails do not fade
several years later his talk with a
friend turns to the Turkish Bo in fact
he has a trail on it it is an
interesting trail pertinent to the
discussion so he sets a reproducer in
action photographs the whole trail out
and passes it to his friend for
insertion in his own mimics
[Applause]
so at the end of the trail we would end
up with a spool of microfilm that would
be mailed or otherwise courier to your
colleague the animation allows you to
point at particular parts of the machine
such as the keyboard and if you'd like
to go back and run over that demo we had
in mind here was the sort of keyboard on
the mechanical calculators at the time
likewise if you wanted to review just
how he also invented pen computing you
could take a look at that what he had in
mind as to how you could write on this
film and somehow record it back on the
microfilm has kept particularly vague in
the article likewise if you'd like to go
in and look at the mechanism as Alfred
Cryme did we we did render somehow the
sort of microfilm transports and
projectors that might make this work but
as far as the demo goes I think the
close the closer you get to this
mechanism the less likely it is that it
ever worked this animation as well as
that small QuickTime video of Bush is
available on our website that's WWE a
mcdowell and we'll do what we can over
the next day or so to put it on the same
website as the rest of the material here
and again I'd like to thank you nadell
minh for doing this work and thank you
very much Andy Van Dam for giving us the
opportunity to show this off people are
interested in having cops these copies
of this please speak to me later and
we'll figure out a way of getting copies
to everybody thank you
[Applause]
we're running a little bit behind
schedule but this is supposed to be an
informal research symposium so let's
have a couple of questions from the
audience if anyone wants to follow up
any of these trails then Paul
established for us
[Music]
just to say in fairness to Bush he did
write another article about mem X in 67
and he did give up on the microfilm
stuff in favor of digital technology he
did figure out that that was the way to
go I entirely agree he did write that
article in fact he wrote several
articles that's the only one that was
published and I didn't mean to suggest
that he didn't want to talk about mem X
what I'm suggesting to you is that when
people would interview him and when he
was noted as a famous person no one
seemed to be interested in this
particular part of his invention after
that after the the initial interest in
this in 45 which seems incredible to us
now since that's all that we remember
but people in the 60s remembered him and
were very interested in him for quite
different things any other questions
ok thank you very much well I'd like to
indulge myself just before introducing
our first speaker by telling you my
particular trail to Bush I started
looking at the problems of large scale
electronic documentation for the Navy in
1960 and my first year in graduate
school I did my master's thesis on a
Blue Point blueprint repository using
microfilm technology in fact we had
millions and millions of aperture cards
which were IBM cards with 35 millimeter
microfilm inside and you could work on
the computerized part as if it were just
a vanilla IBM card and then still have
the benefit of large scale information
storage on the image in fact in 1965 I
wrote a paper my first real paper on a
technical information retrieval system
that combined not just microfilm
but nano fish now I just want to show
this little cultural artifact to you
anybody know what this is there's a
little tiny square I'll give you a clue
it was handed out at the 1964 World's
Fair in the NCR pavilion anybody all
enough to remember that mm-hmm this is
nano fiche its NCR's photochromic micro
image technology it was a grain 'less
organic dye and this is twelve hundred
and eighty pages of the King James
version of the Bible absolutely crystal
clear under the right kinds of optics
this had huge information density so in
my system I thought we should combine
the best features of information
densities for storage purposes and
boolean retrievals based in my case on
an associative memory simulation called
multi lists that had done by far been
done by faculty members at Brown
University in 1967 I met Ted Nelson an
old college friend and a computer
conference and he persuaded me to think
of our brand new IBM 2250 display as
more than just a graphics tube seduced
me into thinking about hypertext instead
of all those nice line drawings
introduced me to Bush from that came our
joint effort on the hypertext editing
system in 67 and 68 I learned about NLS
the online system and Doug Engelbart in
68 and went on to build a multiple
number of other hyper media and
electronic book systems and helped found
iris and the electronic book
technologies I've also been assigning
this wonderful article to almost three
decades worth of generations of students
with that introduction let me get to
what I think is really an important part
of the program not merely the first
speaker but a very special speaker
I think of Doug Engelbart as the pioneer
not merely a pioneer he started at
Stanford Research Institute and his work
enormous Lee influenced researchers at
as you notice when he says to jump I ask
how high okay
start the introduction I thought I was
Robert ready thank you
so Doug's Doug did his work with his
colleagues on the online system at SR I
but their work enormous ly influence
what happened in the early 80s at Xerox
Palo Alto Research Center and that as we
know led to things like Lisa and Mac at
Apple which in turn led to Windows at
Microsoft and so on so there is an
enormous ly visible trail from Doug to
our industry as it exists today and I
hold him and his group personally
responsible in the good sense I want you
to know for building augmentation
systems but he also thought about how
tool building should help the end user
he thought about the process of
introducing new tools and how processes
must change in the organization how the
organization itself had to evolve to
make use of the tool God is familiar
with the term bootstrapping bootstrap
Institute bootstrapping yourself in your
organization he and his people put on
what is still today in my mind and other
people who remember it the mother of all
demos it is still unsurpassed and
happened at the fall joint Computer
Conference it was beyond bleeding edge
and it came off beautifully we're going
to be privileged to see a little footage
from that in a moment and finally very
personally after I learned about him I
was privileged to spend a couple of days
in his lab stealing his best ideas and
implementing many of them in our next
hypertext system called fresh in the
late 60s Doug it's a thrill for me to
welcome you here
[Applause]
well thank you very much this is a real
treat and it left me a little bit a wash
and trying to trying to tell what I'd
like to tell as something that fits into
the bush picture and I think the best
thing I can do is go sit down and start
giving a presentation one thing though I
can tell you is my first introduction to
the bush thing happened it's just
slightly less than fifty years ago maybe
three or four weeks less than that that
there was a young sailor boy that was
plunked down on an island in the
Philippines to wait assignment to some
local area work he was electronic
technician he'd been 2 years of
electronic technician training and
shipped out and variants ting ly that
just as his ship was backing out and
steaming around the San Francisco Bay to
go out there are many many whistles and
toots and everything else and we thought
gee do they celebrate everybody leaving
that way and turned out was VJ day and
so 68 days later at 8 knots we got out
to the Philippines etc but in waiting
around for a week or something like that
and that camp right part of the jungle I
wandered around one day and I found this
Filipino hut they they really are up on
stilts and animals little underneath it
was all nice and clean and it's a Red
Cross library so I climbed a little
ladder it was a very pleasant room in
there about 20 feet on a sign it
actually was a very nicely outfitted the
library and with the thousands of
Marines and sailors around like that
there wasn't a single other person in it
so I I spent hours there so I found that
Life magazine article on Bush and I
always remember it was very exciting to
see that and I'd have enough technical
training by then to look at it and think
about it
sorry so it didn't become an impact
thing that drove me the rest of the time
but I'd like to do is go to sit down
here now and tell you the stories of
what and what to me it the potential is
and I would very very much like to have
been able to work with Bush and talk to
him and I tried one once sending him a a
letter and sort of an outline draft I'd
made and I didn't hear back from him
this was in 1962 and it somebody had
told me that he he's already so old and
he read he was in a rest home or
something it probably wasn't returning
well turns out he lived another 12 years
and published books etc so but I wasn't
aware of that then one of the things
that you have to realize is living way
out there in the Palo Alto area that you
tend to feel that MIT was the center of
the universe then and then just to prove
it that I worked for years by 1962-63
really that might push started in 1951
about committing a career to trying to
do the most to help humans cope better
with complexity and urgency and
computers and interactive use was the
idea that came to my mind and I actually
envisioned how that would work and that
engineering training and the technology
and the radar made me realize that
anything a computer if it could punch
cards and print print on paper it could
create any kind of image you you wanted
on on a screen and it could interact
with humans easily interactively it
so I just pictured it working
interactive well of course this is a
very naive country boy you understand
that it's still a country boy but anyway
so I says all right there's a direction
I'll go back to graduate school and
Berkeley had a research program in
computers they had no in our contract to
build one and I got my PhD five years
later or something and still wasn't
working my man but anyway the in the
first computer conference I went to was
down at UCLA in 1953 I guess and
practically you know it was D that years
computer conference and I think there
were 65 people are you know lecture hall
and in UCLA so if you think back in the
history of things like that you have to
realize the emergence very slowly of
something the rest of the world wasn't
paying much attention to and so the cost
of things relative to salaries etc was
much higher than it is now anyway for me
the that pursuit of saying what can you
do to help work with complexity and
urgency in which the real problems
humanity faces those are collective
problems and so from the beginning it
was the collective capability of people
to cope better and so after I don't have
time to go into all of the the Odyssey
through the years but my SR I until 1977
then SR I sold sold rights to this MLS
system on the commercial world otherwise
we lost our research and they were money
and they were going to dismantle it so
we got a chance to take it out some of
us the people went to Xerox PARC we so
we live in the commercial world selling
the service of this system out to time
net and an ARPANET and a lot of pilots
it was built to support people and work
and and then McDonnell Douglas bought
the time
and time net in 1984 which gave me the
opportunity to go knocking on the doors
of this heavy industrial domain talking
about the kind of things that I'd been
wanting to do for a long time and had
built and it was very interesting that
the architectures that we devolved were
the first thing that appealed to them
it's essentially a very sturdy prototype
of the client-server model with very
special ways in which you could deal
with you could deal with variable
variable classes of workstations and
variable classes of users looking into
the same work domain but then they they
got interested in the hyper structure
group where things to and that that just
opened people's eyes immensely during
all that time the we built a system to
use it and it evolved under constant
heavy use to do all of our work so and
by the time we'd gone out and worked
with other organizations and seen what
happens when you introduce things like
that and get people to adapt themselves
to use it our image about the problems
the challenges of potential requirements
etc grew to be somewhat different from
the rest of the hypertext world which
was was a problem in itself because it
made it harder to be to be part of that
world
so anyway the so anyway in 1989 my
daughter Christina and I formed
bootstrap Institute of saying the real
need here is a strategy for how the
world can really go after the potential
of boosting its collective
problem-solving capability and began
using the term collective IQ in a very
real sense so the the presentation here
is all built around these boxes about
eight or ten of them our paradigm issues
of some significance and had it occurred
to me after quite a few years that the
to walk up cold to people and start
telling them the potential that was
there
the path to go after it we had a great
deal problem because of the ways our
minds get fixed about certain things we
grow up in an environment and we just
take much for granted
so these paradigms are the important
ones and in this presentation I can just
go highlight any of these boxes in this
way or I have also the option of saying
show me a brief little subtitle under it
so I'll march to the subtitles giving
orientation and then dive down
underneath some of these boxes more
deeply to give the kind of presentation
so way of characterizing the objective
here really is high-performance
organizations that means their ability
to cope with complexity et cetera
whether it's developing new products or
coping with national issues and if
you're going to make a really difference
in that it became apparent very early in
my studies by the early 60s that you had
to deal with the whole capability
infrastructure of an organization not
just think you could make some
high-level capabilities improve a lot by
some veneer layer thick new technology
no and in fact really with all studies
out you realize that with all the
technology bringing in it joins the
ranks of a lot of artifacts and tools
through all the centuries any one of
which being introduced if it's any
significance makes a difference in human
organization structure conventions a lot
of things there so the real thing is the
whole that augments the native human
capability is the mix of these both in a
coherent system and to focus on tools
alone if you're going to talk about very
significant improvements in the
technology that focus is not enough to
just on that so we'll go into more of
that later and then the need for a
pragmatic way in which both sides of
those are going to Co evolve the human
system side has just evolved organically
through all the centuries without much
explicit attention but when the
technology started erupting
during world with explicit focus on it
etc then it sort of that was driving the
world and the rest of it follow and so
one says that's going to be very complex
issue problems if we're going to invest
a lot and evolving our organizations etc
and be nice instead of step by step by
step investments that we had some way to
invest in the change that compounded
there'll be a huge social investment
really in this change and so the
technology side of it may only be 10 or
15 percent of the total cost if that
much and so how do you want the best
strategy say like that well do you want
a criteria for investment yes that whole
set on them right so what came out of
this in the end was it be very important
to make pay attention to the
infrastructure of the way our
improvement processes and change
processes work which is a very haphazard
way as it is now it turns out that if
you're looking for sort of the most
payoff investment criteria that paying
attention to the improvement
infrastructure gives you a real chance
to get a hold of a strategy and out of
that comes a sort of a strategy of
saying look if you're going to improve
the end capability for instance in
product cycle time if you also can at
the same time be trying to use some of
the similar capabilities that you're
going to improve to improve your
improvement process you'll really start
bootstrapping and that's the basic thing
diagrams I had in my 1962 paper Oh Sara
like that we're just full of all that
kind of feedback between elements and
such and realizing so it turns out that
this this kind of collective knowledge
work you know that concurrently
developing integrating and applying
knowledge and any collective sense is a
real key to their it's an extremely
important end product for organizations
to have improved but if you do get some
of this going in small groups even and a
high level of new capability in that you
can plug that into an improvement cycle
to accelerate it so that's
the things so that's why we call it
bootstrapping improving your improvement
process thinking yourself up by the
bootstraps so that's a strategy we're
trying to tell the world about so yep
the old guy is still pushing like crazy
cuz it's raising so then you find out if
whatever technologies our capabilities
you're bringing in there they have to
have a sense the global interoperability
that this is really going to be a
collective thing the conventions that
they were showing about in documents
about footnotes how you cross-reference
things make indices table of contents
those are conventions that go along with
the technology of the time you bring in
a brand new technology and there's a new
set of conventions that you want to
adopt to take advantage of those and
those in turn are dependent upon the
structure and conventions by the
electronic form of documents so those
have to grow into something globally
interoperable and as they get those
standards they don't want to be derived
by shallow sort of potential uses
because there's a very deep very broad
very high performance in the end
collective capability you've got to pay
attention to so the pursuit of something
called an open hyper document system
under there is a very very high order
business to be attending to so we say
and how should that be done so it really
needs to be done in a in a pursuit
that's working towards this kind of goal
so a very interesting article item here
becomes how do you start best deploying
early gains and down there you realize
early gains aren't necessarily going to
be the most payoff if you try to bring
everybody in the organization up but if
you can bring special teams of people up
where you really explore the potential
and they have a role in the organization
as it is now there's a lot of reasons
that from our experience they'll just
make that be one of the high payoff
things to consider so you have choices
all the way along of what you what you
improve and where you invest the actual
improvement capabilities that you're
gone so in the end that comes out to be
networked improve
communities are strategically and
extremely important sort of thing that
you get a community of people trying
that they're going to share the
improvement pursuit within that
community you get them connected to a
network and you give them these new
capabilities so that they can cooperate
on that improvement process
it says great especially if you want to
say hey what about the pursuit of this
collective Kodiak stuff why not do that
in this same sense as an improvement
community and at the same time you're
really pushing the best open hybrid
document system potential you can so
that seemed like such a glorious kind of
potential thing to do that that's why we
started the bootstrap Institute to say
to people look there really is something
there we can go after and the company
that learns best to do this is going to
be ahead the country that learns best
how to go after this it's going to come
out ahead and maybe even mankind how
much fuller impact the chances of
survival of the human race that so far
isn't paying much attention to keeping
its world something that is a longtime
survival environment social problems
economic problems political issues and
problems psychological ones many kind of
issues there are really severe and they
put to test our collective capability
which if you look at it isn't a very
good scheme so I'll go down under this
box a little bit to check this thing
like this that in the early 60s after a
decade of having this dream of gold and
doing other things in the way but I got
a chance to start trying to write a
framework paper about hey how can you
any augment and as I started listing all
the neat things you could doing the
tools that's when it really dawned on me
that you have to list these other things
that are given to the raw human being as
he merges into a society in order to to
be capable of operating so the net
capability is the basic human mental
sensory motor bundle of potentials in
there that have to be trained
conditioned etc etc in order to read he
harvests give him all of this and train
condition etc inside of that and this
system augments the human so that's all
we have and so attacking things into
here have that same fundamental well I'd
our already been in the late fifties
just realizing that all my dreams of
this depend upon the assumption that
computer technology digital technology
is going to be very much cheaper very
much faster very much higher capacity at
cetera cetera like that and the only
potential is if it really gets much much
smaller so they were talking about the
you know chips putting all the stuff on
ships etc so I did I got a research
grant to do a study about the
dimensional scaling of electronic
components that means as you cut
everything down by a factor of say ten
well different phenomena shift in a
different rate some of the phenomena
depend upon cross-section areas some
upon the linear dimension some amount of
volume so each of those you know
characteristics or something is going to
change differently with the change in
scale if you have a device that depends
upon the interrelationship of this
phenomenon this phenomena and things get
smaller they just might get out of
contact and they really will an airplane
won't fly just by making it you know
one-tenth the scale unless you keep a
certain combination of parameters
constant etc so one of the things then I
read was in biology a lot of interesting
things about the scale in biology why
why north of Spitsbergen there aren't
any animals mammals smaller than the Fox
well it turns out that the surface area
to volume increases as you get smaller
you make something half the size it's
got one quarter of the surface area but
one-eighth the volume so one eight two
the volumes got to generate whether it's
metabolism the heat to lose over a
quarter that you know you've got twice
as much space for unit volume surface
per unit volume to have to support heat
so you get down a certain size you can't
do it and many other things so one of
the one of the real dozens of that stuff
I was in some interesting to know I
became convinced okay
semiconductors are gonna run out of gas
of a certain size because it's just
basic phenomena but there a lot of other
phenomena they'll start being able to
effective and so the whole push in in
nano technology is just exactly right so
they're inevitable things going to start
happening like that so that the speed
speed price cost anything you're just
going to we haven't even started yet so
the on the right you look at things on
the right side there and say the the
change and scale of capability on the
right of the tools we're going to be
able to have and that domains that can
operate in and the pervasive impact in
this side are going to be of a scale
change we've never experienced before in
history when when a terribly terribly
terribly primitive people found they
could harness fire or find that could
put skins together make clothing or make
shelters those are very significant high
scale impacts on their world and the
left side would change a lot but since
history started and we became aware of
how the left side here can change we've
never had to accommodate something such
a big transition then so we're totally
unprepared and if we were prepared just
because of scaling phenomena we'd start
looking up and down all this thing and
say what are the candidates for change
in almost any category in the human
system and you find it's ripe for
candidates for change and they may do it
so one of the problems though that's
been occurring is typifies maybe by 1975
when the world started talking about
office automation that's what we're
going to do over here automate the
office so it's nls system sitting over
there oh my god what a crappy mix of
things that has so hard to learn etc oh
that's way off the beam but it isn't
we're going to be augmenting over here
which means looking at a particular
potential over here you don't look at it
you shouldn't look at it just how it
fits today
how does it fit into different
conventions and practices etc you got to
look and say well how are we going to
evolve so it's this this human
augmentation system plus people gives
you that capability infrastructure and
that's an extremely important sort of
thing to do so anyway it was that that
perspective that led us then into saying
essentially what you're going to talk
about is this dynamic knowledge
repository and browsing and editing this
today we're really getting these things
and Co involved so that with an ordinary
web browser you can start diving down
more deeply into the environment we've
been used to or stay out in the web
world like that so capturing management
repository and integrating the group
where it was sort of a slant but where
did it start shared files of course but
not for one minute did I think about
that I looked at that language aspect in
that human system and said there seemed
to me a very critical thing as you work
with concepts in your mind they're
structured and related etc a lot of
explicit sand some associative yes
but when you externalize those concepts
you give them real symbols in your mind
and work with them and then when you
externalise that that's the real way in
which you share with people work unit
verbally or in writing so what can you
do that's new for candidate well gee you
can try getting at structure so it sort
of tries to map better the structure the
concepts in your mind so it's it's more
than just not linear it's structured and
the relationships between people with a
lot of concepts can have explicit
relationships and you can interlink them
by cross sighting those are two separate
kinds of aspects of it all so you said
oh I don't you know I can look for lots
of different views once I have it in
there the computer can help me put it in
there can help me view it not only move
around there but view it so we generated
quite a few optional views one of the
things we said oh the view of looking at
a page is literally the last thing we
wanted
that's before we publish or something
like that when you're working online we
don't want to bother with pages like
that so that's something where we right
away departed from the rest of the world
WYSIWYG we laughed at it we said later
on you know the last thing you want to
do is make it look like a piece of paper
when you're gonna if you're going to go
print it but what if you want to read it
use it online there are a lot of things
about pages and all that that get in
your way of what you can do and the
browsing shared screen was a important
thing from the very beginning that I
want to be able to work with my
colleagues I'm the very first concept
that was the way so we built that sort
of thing into it so if I am one of the
things I've got to do is you know we're
already running quite late
if I run another two hours what should I
inform and okay another half hour good
all right I'm gonna dive into quick
pictures of some of the things we've
built back there in those days so here
was the first the second interactive
display that we built to run on a second
computer and you say well that's a
pretty big box isn't it
well yeah because you couldn't get
memories in those days that could give
you a bitmap memory so you couldn't make
a bitmap screen so what you had to do
was draw everything you wanted by
deflecting the beam if you want a big
tube that had this ability and bright
beams that was a very high voltage high
accelerated beam that was hard to move
so took big heavy amplifiers to move it
and that those could have very fast
response so you could do it quickly was
hard to do so this box here oops this
box here contains the amplifiers to move
the deflection oh what generates the
display well you see this box over here
has all the stuff that generates the
deflection for the display so the two
together are the display system a
separate from the computer and that was
we had to get that custom-made from
to $80,000 in 1963 or 64 money which was
a lot of money in those days so he says
all right it it was it was expensive to
do that kind of research
so we one of things we want to do is try
different kind of selection devices so
this was one of them a Judy sitting
there holding that we tied it quite a
few of them and one of them we tried was
this beautiful thing we had out of wood
and here's another interesting
connection with fans of our bush or
whatever his van Busche which I didn't
appreciate at the time but I'd seen when
I was an undergraduate or a device
that's made up of a couple of arm
linkages you move a pointer around a
closed area of some chart you've made
and by looking at the wheels that are on
there cetera you can calculate the area
that you've enclosed in this curve and I
wonder how that worked so the professor
said well a wheel that's moving sharp
like that will only resolve the
direction it's rolling in to slide
sideways it won't resolve that component
so it just sums up the component of
displacement in the direction it rolls
well that's all that this was then is
two different orthogonal wheels rolling
on the surface so it's related to the
way that the differential analyzers ball
disk stuff worked like that but I didn't
I didn't think it back she was the
expression to Bush at the time but
anyway that that's just one all the nice
things even though we tried a neat a
neat thing you move your knee up or down
by pushing on the floor or weightless
sideways and we picked the shakiest knee
to get the photograph of course and I
made a head pointer but we the mouse
really worked the other thing is the
parallel input while you're pointing
what are you going to do so we said we
built this and my kids learned it we
talk to each other very simple the
letter A is the first one the two and
receive this whole loans D just totally
binary turns out kids learn it very
quickly you just draw one two four eight
and sixteen on their fingers and tell
them how you kind
and they pick it up right away and then
say look at the alphabet so that makes a
big difference when one's working in
1967 we actually had a system going
where we were having online meetings in
its way
but we went up when we're going to get a
time-sharing system when scaling again
you could get much cheaper higher
resolution speed on a small tube so we
get a bunch of them at a time sharing
for an industrial camera shroud to look
at it and this this produced the video
without the room and we times shared
drawing the pictures on these little
screens like that and so that was an
innovation that let us get a laboratory
equipment out there and so merely having
two big frames like this are seeking a
character generator display generator
for 12 workstations out in the lab and
it took a lot of maintenance you have to
realize that but out in the laboratory a
simple monitor and the key set in a
mouse and a keyboard
these were standard sort of ways and
standard because of the way things
operated was well we experimented with
different interfaces but this is the
typical way stand stand sit there with
mouse key set and shift to the keyboard
and get long literals but the speed of
operation I don't think it's been
equaled since and so I may be one of the
first people the world had a private
workstation in the office just to do my
daily work all the time and the other
people worked out in this bullpen out
here with all of them that was a really
interesting social thing which it was an
important way in which everybody learned
together about Hana Ronin well we want
to give a show in that 1968 things so we
borrowed some of the cameras and get a
tripod up there and borrow people to
come help make camera working and up in
the Brooks Hall in San Francisco we had
a big video projector that could put
something on that screen you could see a
little bit of it now that you could read
from the back of the auditorium and we
had to ship we had a lease newly and you
know they'd go out put temporary video
links from s RI to the 35 or 40 miles up
the city to run this
and up in the front I was sitting in the
console there and there was a camera
above looking down another mounted on
the council looking at me and in the
back of the room was our director
billing me she would put all this
together and so while it was running I
could be demonstrating things and
talking and so we'll run a little bit of
this footage and it's just realize that
it's the system we had been using and
working with so it could be used both as
a presentation thing and it's a work
example the world's first picture of a
mouse this was moving out there on 1/2
the frame you can see the cursor moving
on the other and the way in which the
controls would work was also pictured
like that and one of the things that was
important well Jeff Rula son had been
with us a couple of years by then and
was responsible for a lot of the
architecture underneath and he showed up
today
sitting over here where now works at Sun
so he came online and unfortunately when
I took 20 minutes of clips from that
hour-and-a-half video and putting
together as I picked when Bill Paxton
came to share screen on it instead of
when Jeff would or you could have seen
that so let's let's run a little bit of
that video please and so this is 1968
and I if I known Busch was still alive
and active
we made go along with this rather
unusual setting and the fact that I
remained seated when I get introduced
and the fact that I'm going to come to
you mostly through this medium here for
the rest of the show and I should tell
you that I'm backed up by quite a staff
of people between here in mineral park
or Stanford Research is located some 30
miles south of here and if everyone was
does our job well we'll all go very
interesting I think the research program
that i'm going to describe to you is
quickly characterisible by saying if in
your office
as an intellectual worker were supplied
with a computer display backed up by a
computer that was alive for you all day
and was instantly responsible responsive
infant a responsive every action you had
how much value could you drive from that
well this basically characterizes what
we've been pursuing for many years in
what we call the Augmented human
intellect Research Center at Stanford
Research Institute
so look what else we can do in here I've
got this file that's structured if I
want to see what's in there I can walk
down
[Music]
the hierarchy levels in see or return
but there's another thing I can do this
route I said I have here
so here I'm afraid I'll need a different
picture than you so here's what I do
with a picture drawing capability here's
a slight and lamp if I start from work
and here's the view I seem to have to go
to to pick up all the materials and
that's my plan for getting home tonight
but if I want to I can say the library
what am I supposed to pick up there I
can just point to that you know I see
overdue books and all while there was a
statement there with that name on it go
back what if I what am I supposed to
pick up the drugstore mm-hmm I see
you've everything all right market oh
I've already seen that I don't like that
J that's too much anyway so we have this
feature the structuring our material
they are quickly they give them to move
around it very well
when we get a hierarchy
such as I can show you here
I can do things if I want to just say
I'd like to interchange produce and camp
materials and go they're all numbered
write me if I care to look interchanging
them very quickly cans are going to get
interchanged with produce they do it and
all gets me numbered so I have ways it's
studying over making different views
moving around going to specified points
and modifying the structure at the same
time I seen that I have a repertoire of
different entities my character knock
off that character replace the character
make that P so I have entities of all
sorts that I can say I want to do
operations on and this basic structure
that I can move over and study and get
about very quickly so that is the
essence No
that's the essence of the tool we have a
lot of details that I've left out for
you and now I'd like to stop a minute
and just make sure you understand we're
shifting from illustrative material to
the real working stuff in case you
wouldn't recognize that otherwise we've
had we've used this tool to do our daily
work and it's our system has been built
this time sharing system for about six
months now it's been working and in that
time we've gone from it getting one
console they're getting about six
looking now with six more do the rest of
spring is our fourth computer which
we've had this kind of a system so we've
learned a lot about user features we
want and how to be fairly skillful but
this next step about learning how when
you're faced with having this in your
office all day as I now do a very
exciting sense how do you put that to
work for yourself how do you organize
your files what kind of things do you do
so to get going on this let's switch
away from the tool we have here and talk
about some of the general features of
the program some of the ways it's built
and get back a little later to the
nature of the of our use each other so
that program involves about 17 people
together with a special laboratory
facilities we have it's sponsored by
government agencies exclusively ARPA
NASA and our ADC now and in the past Air
Force are an ESD and these are the
people that first grubstaked as many
years ago all right and it's been a
goal-oriented pursuit for many years and
I think we can just go off and get a
quick little picture I sketch to show
this is the staffing over the years from
1950 on and has had slightly bumpy
history during these years there was
only one of us
I go back to I was and say let's
continue on in this file that link took
me up to a different file to a statement
for that view and I jump back to this
flower where I was and not within this
file I make a link to another to say the
hir see is pursuing these goals basic go
and prove the effectiveness with which
individuals and organizations work at
intellectual tasks what does their
effectiveness involve them better
solutions faster solutions solutions to
more complex problems better use of
human capabilities really thinking about
that but a corollary goal is besides
improving the effectiveness to develop a
system oriented discipline for designing
the means by which greater effectiveness
is achieved that's very important what's
the approach for this shouldn't result
in this system oriented disciplined let
me just show you how I constructed this
file you notice underneath there with
that and that there was just a link
hidden here it went back to this view
with a slightly different view
parameters
to give you that do alright there's
another one hidden here it says the
general approach for us
empirical we're pursuing this monstrous
goal monstrously difficult to by
building and trying directly and we're
approaching an evolutionary wise because
we feel that it's a whole system problem
you need to get a person in that
environment working and looking at the
many aspects of his working system that
are involved in his effectiveness that's
many more things than just these
computer-aided tools in a large system
like that we need to do it evolutionary
wise because we can't be analytic enough
about it at any one point to decide what
best our next thing should be we can
read aside from here as well as we can
analyze it where we can invest our next
resources to get the most return at an
increase of the effectiveness of the
system we have and this item down here
is the term bootstrapping applied in a
slightly new sense or applying that to
our approach where we're saying we need
a a research subject group to give them
these tools put them to work for them
study them and improve them
aha we'll do that by making ourselves be
the subject group and studying ourselves
and making the tools so that they
improve our ability to develop and study
these kinds of systems and to produce in
the end this kind of system to spunk so
it's been awful it's a struggle doing it
that way but it's beginning to pay off
oh I was attempting to run that these
are clips taken from an hour and a half
and there were a couple things in there
I really wanted to get to but the time's
running too short
we brought during that I want to have
three different people were tuned in oh
that their faces appeared in here and we
were seeing their work or we were
sharing the screens together etc and one
of them I was hoping to get there and
show you but
these videos are available people might
be interested in them but what I wanted
to do was come back to this screen here
and do them they're right that we sort
of saw the mix in here and then those
intervening years after that we did a
lot of things that were much what's
beyond what we've been talking about
here and the when we got here and we
were talking about this is the kind of
thing we displayed at the time here and
they were shared files so and our
software was all being done that way and
when Jeffrey Wilson was one whose face
was brought up and he was showing the
structure and all of the software it's
there like that but the next thing we
did was integrate email because the next
two years later we started operating on
the network at the second node on the
ARPANET and we were to provide the
Network Information Center
so we were providing integrated email in
which these were the hyper objects that
could interlink between email and to the
shared file at the same time another
thing which is a very significant sort
of part of our work which has it I don't
see it used yet out there but just made
of immense difference in how the
dynamics of the dialog go on in there
that when you submit a document to this
software and administrative operations
system called the journal it would get
cataloged you would do it this way
similar to launching an email with more
new fields that could go into the
catalog and instead of sending the
content and a message you could just put
a link to some other file and that would
get catalog and then the system
guaranteed that any anytime ever more do
you access that by a link or any other
way you were guaranteed you'd get what
the author published on that time and
the publication was not just a year like
they are now but a day
in a minute down there because a few
minutes later somebody could have put a
response in its cited yours etc so the
dynamics of all of that for managing
dialogue flow was just difficult when
you watch email and a lot of conference
things out there and you realize you
can't do that in there the anyway it's
it's very significant difference to that
well I we can literally spend hours in
all of this and if I want to be any kind
of a friend of Andy Van Dam's in the
future I'd better see what's it worth
Andy the one thing that really helped me
a lot in trying to portray to people
what I sense about all this is to take
those two major dimensions of the
augmentation system and make it like a
frontier you have to realize that each
of these dimensions in turn is a
multi-dimensional vector and to array
that along a vector line such that you
can say that's increasing system
improvement would be hard to put done
but just picture it that way and we can
picture today out here some frontier
boundary but we're pretty sure in 20
years they'll be technologies available
to harness that they're way beyond that
but similarly people are beginning to
realize about the process reengineering
that's potentially available the new
skills the new roles etc that can go on
the organizations those all make
something in this vector our
organizations are all clustered down
here now the product people are maybe
the most of them are out here someplace
close to the edge of what organizations
can use but they're not going to make
things that organizations can't use yet
so what does an organization if somebody
brought up a technology that was way out
here that could really provide really
new changes would there be any market
for it they wouldn't
there's no market pull from the large
user organizations that clusters or
communities that could benefit by this
new collective capability they don't
know they don't have the experience to
know what they want to yet because this
is an unexplored frontier exploration
has got to be more than just people
writing papers or a few graduate
students trying something take sports
you really have to put up a group of
people it's going to live that way to do
heavy knowledge work that's
representative of what it's going to be
like when they're part of a larger
collective organization and it's like
saying we need outposts out there well
you could put one out there now that use
the forefront of what technology and the
product line could cause or somebody
could bring out some brand new
technology and sort of say you can
harness that in the most advanced
process engineering organization but
where as far as this as a frontier and
where is this and where is the
responsibility lie in our society for
exploring that frontier enough so any
kind of interested organization says god
we've got to get out there because if we
don't the ones who do are going to win
that's true for a country - so who's
going to do the exploring because it's
very different from a group of people
that can make an exploratory technology
and demonstrate it this is where you've
got two people who have adopted their
learning and working basis in there
that's in a way that's like you says oh
that's representative enough of how my
or whole organizations work or some
significant part of it
I'll move one department or one division
or something out there now all right you
have to realize that the cost of moving
vertically in this space is much higher
than moving horizontally and that if the
horizontal thing keeps plugging out
there and forces organizations to zigzag
out here that's extremely expensive they
say our industry and the product people
would never do that would they well ha
you know the personal computer field was
about 10 years old before they started
doing anything
with the networks and yet when they
began 11 12 years ago it was clear that
then 11 12 13 years of experience with
the ARPANET where it's very clear that
anybody's going to really work
significantly at an interactive terminal
wants to be connected and yet they were
no provision for it in fact it was
rejected very adamantly by sort of like
the guy that went around says of all
Jesus none of the girls in this county
want to get married how do you know I
asked him so it's sort of like I asked
these guys
how about connecting and I'd get very
flat pictures that that's not what you
want to do well anyway that's 10 years
of lost opportunity for our society to
start learning how to harness all this
thinking about etcetera so we've got to
do better and whoo so there are several
possibilities you know cooperative
collective and user organizations or
communities that get together to start
investing in it a government role could
be in there too a government role could
be there to say let's let's if we get
communities of users that say hey enough
of us of significant going to want to
set up an outpost that they could start
underwriting some of the technology here
that could do that for that group if
they get the feedback so they co-evolved
together because they're endless places
in the military and the rest of
government where you could apply much
improve collective and capability so
that's the end of my presentation for
all this and and I really kept wishing
now more than ever that that we had cams
three three half-hour cans of 16
millimeter film or what resulted from
that presentation in 68 and I really
wish I don't known that Bush was still
alive and active and I would have sent
that to him because it could have made a
lot of difference and he's for me to get
connected with him like that
so great data respect for what he he did
etcetera and I wish I hadn't had to go
off somehow
sort of a woman vector and just okay
that that's it
Andy we're still friends
[Applause]
mr. modesty as all
what I like to do is since dog quit
exactly on time is give him the ten
minutes he earned for Q&A and some
interaction with the audience do us a
favor and please go to the microphone
identify yourself and speak up so that
you can be recorded for the record of
course you can always just pass on it we
can quit anyone to the microphone Bob
calm those reels of tape to Vannevar
Bush what kind of reaction do you think
you might have gotten back well that's a
very good question Bob
I'm sorry you asked it what what my
experience had been from the 50s even
for many I mean still often is people
that I would have thought would get
excited about it would get turned off or
would feel like that you know I was
invading some domain as a alien stranger
who didn't understand that domain and
was talking about bringing toys to bear
that didn't seem relevant you know one
things experience that stands out very
much in my mind in the very early 60s 60
or 61 I had a chance to visit it was
invited to come and talk to the group at
the Institute for behavioral science or
something like this that were the people
who came on a year's sabbatical to
Stanford and sat around and thought and
talked about behavioral science so I
went over to talked about this time and
afterwards sitting out in the patio at a
picnic table with four of them I started
to get really beaten up and turns out
one of the guys had been specializing in
information retrieval for decades or
something like
and he felt honestly felt sort of
violated that here's somebody talking
about some bringing some toys and it
didn't understand what information
retrieval was about that the
professionals have it under control and
that I should just get out I don't have
the same years of experience without
people in psychology people in social
science people that uh I would get that
very often through the years and so I if
if Bush had gotten back in touch I I
wouldn't have been terribly surprised if
he responded that way but but I'd kept
trying and I was just delighted if if
with his experience that said are out
there in his contacts if he could have
sort of participated with me somehow and
saying okay we're next did I answer if
your work had not been interrupted in
the mid 70s at SR I and funding a
continued at a high level what are some
of the other things that you think you
would have worked on well we we had a
program actively started of of enlisting
organizations that could access us to
the ARPANET to start burning and trying
and we would have been just going after
that that bootstrapping
where you you know you come into an
organization and you can't expect them
all to go change so and you can't you
can't expect just wheel in a bunch of
the truckload of Technology and expect
them to change so we start out by saying
you have to appoint somebody hopefully
not a programmer that we're going to
call the architect of your knowledge
workshop and that has to be a person
that the user group that they're
interested in respects this person is
understanding their work and their job
etc and that person is gonna be the
architect working together and we
support that person and learn a lot from
that person and going involved so we had
a prototype community like that going
that all just got clobbered
etc but then there are many many
technical things that we just were
waiting to do we very much would like to
have added speech so you could have
recorded speech inside of there and of
course the graphics would have been
better and you know to learn how to
interface with CAD systems and database
systems like so that a lot of evolution
I just I still think it's there to go
after and the things we've been doing
now are realizing that the world wide
web just gave the world an extremely
exciting stimulus it just was it's a
priceless thing and it to be very nice
if somehow that momentum can carry on to
say look not just for publishing but
let's move that kind of capability into
what we do every day and in a by a
minute so every memo I write is linkable
to you let's make it so every object in
it is addressable intrinsically then I
don't have to go put a tag on it and
purpose so if somebody can cite it
there's a list of about 15 things like
that I wrote down last spring that
anyway I I'd be giving you the whole
lecture just to follow up on this
speculation of what might have happened
if you've gotten a little bit better
communication channel with dr. Bush when
we we found your letter in the MIT
archives around 1962 and from what we
could tell his health had been up and
down at that point and he clearly wasn't
around when the letter arrived and it
was a secretary who responded now just
also to give a little perspective there
was a large there's a large technology
effort here at MIT in 1965 I believe
called the int Rex project at the
library where they were trying to create
the library of the future back in the
past and they were doing this with
combination of microfilm readers and
electronic computers and they made a
tremendous effort to get him to both
come and speak at a large conference and
interact with the people thinking that
he would be interested because they felt
that what they were doing was clearly
related to his work and at that point
he'd really distance himself from this
he was willing to come and
give a ten minute speech but he didn't
seem to be all that interested in
interacting with people who were
following it and I think part of it is
this paradigm issue that that you were
on the other side of he was very much an
analog machine person and he felt rather
uneasy with people who were dealing with
digital machines because he wasn't the
expert in digital machines he was the
expert in analog machines and I think
you were you in a way were suffering
from that problem you were a future
expert on a technology that most of the
experts at the time didn't really
understand I just learned a lot of that
what I really think is that the biggest
limiting factor in whether our society
or how fast our society can really
integrate the potential of all of this
rests upon the paradigm shift factor I
call it the paradigm shift listless that
it's a very natural thing and I felt
very injured by it for a while and then
then I this introspection you're
supposed to do I realize I do it to see
that people can be trying to tell me
something for quite a while and somehow
later when I find out that's what they
were trying to tell me then it's easy to
be angry at them because they didn't
really explain it right I'd like the
privilege of the last question Doug what
do you think the hardest several
research problems are that remain to be
solved at this point what do you think
we need to put our focus on
well I I think it's the research
environment is the biggest thing is
getting where you've really got groups
of people that are committed to really
change and that and in my sense to get
to get then you almost have to recruit
advertise recruit and put through basic
training and equip and train like you
would if you said I'm I'm going to take
a bunch of flat land people and train
them to be ski troop there's something
you got equipment training before you
can start learning what it's going to be
next so that's that's what I feel
high-performance teams are something we
should really go after okay with that
again it was terrific it was a privilege
having you here
it's a great pleasure to introduce Ted
Nelson who was first the creative force
behind what was arguably the first rock
musical and still as you'll see a
showman to the core he is of course the
coiner of the word hypertext and many
other evocative terms and ideas and I'm
especially grateful to him for making me
see its potential not just for technical
documentation which I was focused on
when we met but especially for changing
education and scholarship we work
together in 67 and 68 on the hypertext
editing system with my students and I
have to say it was always interesting
always intense and hyper frenetic he's
well known to most of you for computer
lib dream machines and that was one of
the very first books that tried to make
ordinary folks understand the magic of
computers and everything that they would
be able to do for us even today
it makes for entertaining and insightful
reading he's also the coiner of an
aphorism that I've really enjoyed
mentioning all these years which is that
if computers are the wave of the future
then surely displays are the surfboards
and computer graphics being my
profession I've practiced that most
recently and actually for multiple
decades he is the prophet of Xanadu and
its implications for writing
communication commerce intellectual
property rights and a number of other
things that he will be addressing today
Ted welcome back
[Applause]
it was a great pleasure to be here today
um the other the 30 years ago I had the
extremely unpleasant experience of going
to graduate school at a place I liked
very much which is Harvard and I loved
the quality of the institution and hated
the character of graduate school because
it wasn't like going to college where
ideas were your métier where ideas were
the substance of what you were doing
rather it was a kind of serfdom in an
the complex academic structure of
obligations and annoyances that had very
little to do with learning well this was
a lesson education is a complex business
you have to make your own education by
whatever means they give you a
curriculum what you have to do is you
have to take that curriculum and twist
it to make it yours No
there's always a paradigm confrontation
when I talk to most audiences because
the viewpoints tend to be so very
different mine and everyone else's this
however in this present circumstance is
especially peculiar because the audience
at this conference is so distinguished
the it's hard to distinguish the
audience from the speaker's somewhere on
the some are on the list of speakers but
there are many eminent persons out there
and of course we have this marvelous
array of video equipment infallible
stuff and so here buoyed by the new
technology we can talk about things and
in a spirit common to the what we all
feel about the media world of the future
and how it should be and so among you
colleagues I feel a little different
because I've been at war with the world
all my life and yet amongst you guys
some of whom I feel our deep friends and
some of whom I feel some have felt some
enmity toward yet I feel this is a
spiritual home and I can say what I
really mean for a change and not have to
say it slowly so the paradigm
confrontation ordinary to most
discussions is but let's back up Tom
Kuhn coined the term or popular as the
term paradigm to mean the the
overarching system of ideas in which we
live and over the years with the
incredible difficulties I've had
communicating to people and I'm not too
bad with words and so the there was
something deeper here so what why is it
so hard to get these ideas across these
are very simple ideas in 1960 in an
epiphany which would be technically
called a psychotic fugue I realized that
we were coming to what is now called a
media convergence that we would that the
future of person kind would be on the at
the computer screen but all our work and
all our creative
tivity virtually would be virtually at
the computer screen and that the
different media would fuse into a new
combination of movie and interactive
thingamabob which we didn't have a name
for and yet this would also be our new
literature literature being defined as
that collection of connected materials
which passes on to posterity the
connected documents of the world and if
we extend those documents to all sorts
of media objects and then that would be
the new literature and it obviously was
my job to design it I've been trained
for it all my life
and not known it seong III had a
peculiar background I was I was raised
as a yeah by my grandparents in
Greenwich Village
my parents were distant figures in the
theatre they were divorced before I was
born
and my father was was unique in that he
had a hit on Broadway while he was a
pilot instructor in Georgia and then
went on to be an early director in
television and so I got to be on TV I
got to read for theatrical parts and and
be in summer stock with some major
actors when I before I was even in
college and at the same time I was very
theoretical my profoundest memory of
childhood took place when I was either
four or five I know that because it was
in Lincoln Park in Chicago I was riding
with my grandparents in a rowboat my
grandfather was rowing my grandmother
with her high heels was in the front and
I was in the back trailing my hand in
the water and understanding and
expressing things in words it always
been the center of my being a very good
thing for me was that that people
appreciated my ability to put into words
put things into words from an early age
and so I saw the problem of expression
not as pleasing people but as seeing
correctly and formulating correctly and
so as I trailed my hand in the cool
water on that day in Lincoln Park 50 odd
years ago
I sensed the water moving around my
fingers and studied in my mind the
complexity of that pattern of motion and
while I didn't know words like particle
parameter specification yet I thought
about the complexity of expressing that
system of movement that hand shape that
glove shaped system of water and its
motions around my fingers and the fact
that each particle of water every
instant was that the entire situation
every instant was almost identical with
the entire situation in the previous
incident and how hard this was to
express and as I thought of each layer
of complication of this moving structure
I recognized it as one more move one
more remove of expressive complication
and my mind my little mind was boggled
and I was in awe of the expressive
complexity of this tiny universe of
moving water glove shaped moving water
compared to which of course the larger
world was humongously larger and
compared to which the imaginable
universe and all the stars and I was
somewhat versed in astronomy by that was
immensely larger and I was awestruck by
the
conceptual complexity and the expressive
complexity and the magnificence of the
universe and the immensity of the
expressive of the expressive problem in
expressing this universe so that was how
I felt about things when I was four or
five and this problem has stayed with me
this has been my problem the central
problem is how do you express
complicated things and how do you see
them and how do you say them and what
are they and of course this is the
problems science this is a problem art
this is a problem computer graphics this
is a problem software design this is the
problem isn't it so it was a I was off
to a good start I think I've really
screwed it up later but so on the one
hand I was intensely into theatrical and
media forms
I loved my comics by the time I was 10
my comic you know I was a well-to-do
middle class child and by the time I was
10 I had perhaps a 4-foot stack of
comics and I remember the day my
grandfather threw them out he waited
till my grandmother was away because she
wouldn't defend them and I said no no
they'll be valuable someday and he's
scoffed my present estimate was that
they would be worth at least $300,000 at
this point I had ha ha
number one at a complete run of Little
Lulu you know any of it great stuff and
I could tell you about any of those
comics I didn't like the they were
violent stuff but but there are a lot of
elegant things and I studied the
wordings I studied the pictures I study
the printing process I loved magazines I
loved radio radio was so big then and
and radio was so different as a medium
because the sent the family would sit
around the radio and listen and we would
look each other at each other when good
things are exciting things happen in
fact I remember I remember
Pearl Harbor I was sitting on my
grandfather's lap and we were listening
to the symphony I believe when the word
came through and I remember my
grandfather breaking down and weeping
and I remember the virtual end of world
war two because I was listening to the
news I had the radio on in my playroom
at the farm when news of the Hiroshima
bomb came through and I ran back to the
house and explained it I think quite
accurately what I'd heard and I believe
it was that was only a few months after
Vannevar Bush's article as we may think
was published in The Atlantic Monthly
which I believe we read at the lunch
table at the farm my great-grandfather
mr. Edmund Gail Jewett was a an ex
science teacher it was he who instructed
me on astronomy and evolution when I was
small and and he relished scientific
articles and I believe he read this to
us at the table now I'm not sure it
would have been he rather than my
grandfather and but the wit this way of
thinking was always so much with me of
being able to follow not just the
exposition of a teacher and I didn't
like teachers very much but being able
to follow the thought processes of a
researcher discovering something as Bush
points out in as we may think so
this has always been with me but of
course the very notion of understanding
the process of discovery in the
evolution of ideas and thought was very
big to me we had on our coffee table a
big picture book of notebooks of da
Vinci which I just loved we went through
them da Vinci and Shakespeare were like
members of the family and and so to me
you know there was there was no question
of what the great issues of the world
were when I was a child the great issues
of the world were the creative process
the writing process posterity and
I'll mention one other religious
epiphany I had which was when I was
about 10 or 11 there was a movie my
grandmother had told me about for years
and she loved it and she had and and and
it was re-released so I could probably
find out the exact date and she actually
let me play hooky and we went to
Wanamaker's and had an elegant lunch and
then we went and saw not just the
original but the sequel as well a double
feature King Kong and the son of Kong I
have never been so awestruck in my life
it was the most religious experience
I've ever had because it was cinema at
its greatest it was adventure it was and
it was idealism son of Kong at least to
me at that time was a far finer film
because of course King Kong was just a
poor old raging guy but son of Kong was
an idealist he was he was an albino and
and at the end I forget what happens at
Earth there's an earthquake his foot
gets caught in a crevasse but he's
drowned and above the water he is
holding not Fay Wray but her sequel
safely and so in her in his in his
clenched fists which is all you see in
him at last is the heroine
well that was fine stuff and I just wept
and wept and I took a long walk on the
streets just meditating and I just felt
a great compulsion to do something to
express the what I felt about it
I finally eyebrows the fine at five and
ten and I remember finally spending my
last my only 15 cents for a bottle of
red ink somehow there being able to do
something in rent was going to I was
going to express this feeling I felt
that day so colored inks stationary
stores office supply stores were of
where I hung out as a kid I hated sports
bookstores I loved I would play hooky
and go to foreign movies when I was 13 a
movie came out called Rashomon
and I saw it three or four times it
played next door to us and I was
profoundly affected by the telling and
retelling of the same stories the same
story over and over from different
points of view and if one thing ever
said to me that we had to inter compare
things it was the movie rationale so
those just decide a few things those
those are those are things in the my
background were where I was coming from
but I I loved special effects we all do
of course but but I was into them rather
early in when I was 15
what was it 52 I had an American
cinematographers handbook which I read
from cover to cover and I was already
budgeting low-budget movies in my mind I
I was a member of a film society called
cinema 16 it was perfect clear to me
that that anyone could make movies one
of my heroes was a guy named Norman
McLaren who a Canadian cartoonist with
the National Film Board of Canada who
actually drew on the frames he actually
drew song soundtracks and got away with
it's good stuff very cute and layered
effects I was fascinated by three
dimensions from the time I was kid
there's something called the TrueView
which was a 35 millimeter viewer far
better than the than the viewmaster
which came in later and ants and
according to some Gresham's law of media
knocked the viewmaster out of the out of
the business and then came three
dimensional movies House of Wax was well
I don't I think House of Wax was the
first one and the real thrill to me was
to go curtains parted and here was a
trailer said now is the time to put on
your glasses on this hand-drawn Road
this carpet flung out to you in three
dimensions and who was it done by it was
done by Norman McLaren so to me the lone
artist capable of doing anything if you
just don't stand in his way he was my
hero da Vinci
cyrano de bergerac my other great hero
and and the the ringing line III should
know the French I didn't even I I didn't
even know till recently that the
original French play was in poetry
whereas of course the America the
English translations rather clunky but
the but that the last but but but Sarah
those lines like I stand not high it may
be but alone this matched my mood
because I hated committees I hated
producers I hated backers I hated
anybody who wanted you to submit a plan
submit a proposal screw that to Mesa
Rose attitude was die right then submit
and that was mine so what I wanted in
life was the equipment and that was all
and I wanted to be left alone I wanted
nothing to do with committees and every
arguing in high skin in grade school we
were supposed to learn democracy by
having committee meetings well it all it
all it convinced me was that was the
kids the other kids were incredibly
stupid because there were so many layers
of complex conditionals that you had to
understand and that they would fixate on
one thing or the other not get the whole
picture and I just grew sick of it I so
wanted to work alone was was the always
the center of my being that was a then
we took you know the usual cooter
pressed from a preference test in high
schools it you know uh
all these other kids would say oh I want
to work with people no sir no I did not
want to work with anybody and this is
the fundamental district difference
between my wonderful and very great
stepfather Douglas Engelbart and myself
because he wanted to empower working
groups and I just wanted to be left
alone and be given the equipment and
basically to empower smart individuals
and keep them from being dragged down by
group stupidity and the amazing thing is
that our designs have converged to some
degree showing I think the fundamental
validity of this whole approach so
because there's something certainly it
is certainly a fine thing to want to
empower groups and I but I'm just I'm
I'm I'm laying it out from my point of
view I just wanted to get out from under
I hated school one of the profound
experiences my life was the at the end
of
great at the end of my seventh grade a
certain mr. H sent me from the room one
time too many what he didn't know was
that I had already sharpened a small
screwdriver to stab him and I came up
behind him at basketball practice and
thought better of it and the next day
when he sent me from the room he was out
to break me the next time no sir
he sent me from the world room one time
too many and I just kept on going down
the stairs and I refused to go back and
that was a searing experience to me
because on that walk home I basically
decided the fundamental things that have
go to my life ever since that most
people are fools most authorities
malignant God does not exist and
everything is wrong and those have been
my guiding believes ever since and I
finally had to go back to school and
endure it another four years but but
then Collin came College which was like
spring day because there it wasn't that
you had to do this and you had to do
that but you were free to explore and
free to find out stuff and all of the
ideas of the world were laid out before
you and that was what I loved and the
fact that well I loved and believed in
literature but I didn't very much care
for the literature professors where I
was and social sciences were so much
more interesting because here people
were trying to say things precisely they
were trying to say precisely what is it
that makes the person tick how does the
mind work etcetera etcetera etcetera and
it was very clear that all of the
theories were true except in my opinion
Carl Jung but that's another story
and and so essentially the real problem
is how to merge true theories not the
silly notion that we want to find out
which theories are false and do some
sort of axiomatic division and find out
it doesn't wash at all
so I had a few fights with professors
along those scars and
my junior year in college I wrote a
paper in which I fused all of my
philosophical concerns because I had
since that time with my fingers in the
water etc etc I wanted to find out how
to express things how to say things how
do i bracht things how do we get the
correct constructs what how do you
express dependencies and inter-linkages
think of the swirling around this finger
affecting that finger that's a linkage
you need to express and so I wrote this
long I think was about 30-40 pages and
not very long but paper and I called its
schematics systematics nor Mattox and it
was essentially a complete expression of
everything I thought about everything in
a very abstracted form abstract
constructs to a second a third level
that I had a lisp like notation using
asterisks ins and asterisks and
parentheses I think and for expressing
complex dependencies and some stuff on
the theory of strategy I'm a whole lot
of stuff I was very proud of it I sent
out a copies to about dozens of people
and no one ever said anything but I knew
I was onto something I had some
encouragement from one person professor
Michael Scriven a very very brilliant
guy some called him arrogant he was he
was my kind of guy he just he just said
what he thought and he said it very
quickly so you had to be a good listener
but he definitely showed respect for
what I was saying even though most
people couldn't follow it he followed my
every point and so I knew I wasn't way
off base so I was torn between these two
different careers I made my first movie
in college I made a cut an LP I I wrote
plays but I couldn't leave behind these
powerful intellectual questions that I
that that that that sees within man and
and and how to relate
the problem of complex abstract
construction to the world so I graduated
college in 1959 I was torn between these
two areas I had an interview with my
father and our terms had gotten quite
unfriendly we rarely saw each other and
and he asked whether I wanted to go into
show business or academia and I gave the
wrong answer because he would have he
would have set me up as an actor in
Hollywood if I'd give him the right
answer but no no no no I said I want to
do both and and and we hardly ever spoke
again and because I was torn
I saw no reason to give up these two
things I cared about and then the next
year in graduate school I took the
computer course and while I had there
had been a conflict before between the
one point of view which was theoretical
and the other point of view which is
theatrical abruptly I got stereo because
it was absolutely plain that this
machine was a theatre machine it was the
new proscenium of our new arts and at
the same time what did computers deal
with the press had lied everybody said
computers dealt with numbers and this
was nonsense they dealt with arbitrary
constructs so that designing the
arbitrary constructs which should be
central to the media of the future was
plainly the job for which I had trained
23 years so I realised this was my true
work and I did get that done in six
months and go make my movies and that
was 35 nasty years ago the first five
was was was was productive and
the handout I've given you which is my
first paper from the ACM and 90/65 shows
basically I'd done all my thinking then
I should have just died and come back as
a wraith now and and and I'd be some
kind of James Dean or in the field but
unfortunately I had the bad taste to
live on and waste entirely waste 30
years so because I've lived in a
completely different software paradigm
now the interesting thing is first of
all I couldn't explain what I was doing
to anybody except Deborah stone my now
ex-wife was here today but who's been
wonderfully supportive all he did she
understood what I was trying to do but
when I would say to someone on the
street what do you see what I'm trying
to do is build a new literature in which
you have automatic copyright handling by
electronic means since anyone is free to
quote anybody else but they're only
referencing the original object which is
then taken out and the royalty is paid
on a pro-rated provide basis to the
copyright holder on each frame audio
sample or piece of text arbitrary piece
of text
if anybody sat through that during the
sixties they would blink a few times and
then say is it like a tape and I was
mystified by this answer because I I I
never understood people I know know that
some people listen more slowly than
others and so so when I talk there's a
there's an impedance mismatch because I
generally talk fast and it's like trying
to drive a high frequency I don't have a
load impedance mismatch impudence
mismatch whatever the problem is that
you have to match up I once took the
Werner Erhard seminars called the forum
at the time really got my money's worth
and what he basically said is you have
to prepare the listener you can't simply
demand that they understand you and I
wish I'd known that years before but
then again I never had very much regard
for other people and I never had a very
high risk for other people's opinions
which is the only reason it was possible
to think this much ahead because it
didn't matter what they thought so the
same thing that the same ability that to
visualize that allowed me to think ahead
also very much made it impossible to get
anything done
so the paradigm I lived in I have lived
in for 35 years is that we would have
new media objects of arbitrary
dimensionality I loved arbitrary
dimensionality I've been into n
dimension since I was a kid so we have
new to new media of arbitrary
dimensionality which could be tacked
together stretched and flipped at great
speed with interfaces which I would
visualize as being somewhere between a
theremin and a bicycle now a theremin as
you may or may not know is a wonderful
musical instrument devised by a Russian
count who was a hero of Lenin's regime
for a time the theremin you played in
the air I think the right hand on the
side was was volume and the other left
hand above it was pitch and it was
simply an analog device with cross
modulation so you had this eerie sound
which was again popular in 1950s
scientists at science-fiction movies but
the idea that you didn't have to touch
the thing and that you just delicately
shaded it this I like we get that you
know that having to be explicit and do
things one soggy step at a time was was
was tedious I wanted it to have a great
kinesthetic sense my bicycle when I was
a teenager was very important to me
because the great sense of swoop and
turn you had was wonderful and I believe
that that kind of control is what you
should have for your arbitrary travel
through the new space of the media of
the heart and mind and so creating this
arbitrary space arbitrary spaces of new
topologies has always concerned me and
the topology of the control space which
which ought to match fairly well the
control the the topology of the
construct logic that you're dealing with
would then be a sign to some aerial
structure and you ought to be able to
get some exercise along the way I wanted
to stand say let's let's say I'm alone
in my office but but here are various
airborne things and I'm waving my hands
and from there getting audio feedback so
you can hear virtual pages riffle or
virtual levels clatter at the same time
you are doing
you're doing a whole lot of other things
Steve with him who's in the audience and
I once programmed a word processor and
we gave it sound effects that I'm
surprised nobody else has yet for so the
delete went I can't quite do it anymore
but something like and and and going up
to paragraph mode and down a sentence
mode you can hear these things go ding
ding
and it was it's like a video game the
whole point is that you want as much
feedback as possible to I am shocked and
grieved that the video game industry has
had so little effect upon the office
software industry the the the Xerox PARC
model has dominated the office design
now let's put it let me be plain about
this there are many people I like and
respect from Xerox PARC and I like and
respect much of their work but overall
the institution pisses me off very much
I first spoke there in 1972 Alan showed
me the dynami the small talk and stuff
and I was very impressed and thought it
was wonderful but I said what about the
lines that crossed the boundaries of the
window I don't remember the exact
conversation but I was very strong I
believe already on that point that you
had to have pointing lines crossing the
boundaries of the window so something in
one window could explicitly point to
something in another window and they
said well we'll get around to it well
that was 25 years ago guys and you
haven't and we're stuck with mac windows
and windows windows and open look
windows and they're all the same and if
you say which one do you like to me
that's do you want Delmonte ketchup or
ANP ketchup or whatever ketchup on your
cow patty it's all the same thing and
attempting to Cosma ties it cuz medicine
is it differently with with with
slightly variant looks when you should
be doing something entirely different
it really takes me off so that the
another aspect of that was that on my
first visit of his Xerox PARC some guy
followed me from room to room saying I
pity you Nelson I pity you and that left
a very very poor impression amazing
so so I always felt those people were
entirely to pump as the the the Xerox
public relations would have you believe
that Xerox PARC was this happy
playground where we're all these these
these these sweet guys played in their
sandpit and in fact it was a very nasty
place in some ways I felt the atmosphere
was extremely unpleasant I was there
twice and I sure didn't like it and but
anyway this is sour grapes nobody ever
backed me and by the way the five
million dollars that went to the Xanadu
project from 1892 was to XOC
incorporated of which I was simply one
of the major stockholders and not they
and and a figurehead at Autodesk so no
one has ever backed my software I've had
to count up to programs ever done one in
that is to my satisfaction which means
every keystroke
in the in the state diagram and that was
that was in 92 No
79 was was one of them and anyway the in
that area the the the 70s and the point
is that my interfaces are completely
different for example the the the word
processor jot a prose processor I call
it the unit is the the units are
sentence paragraph what was it yeah word
sentence in paragraph and and and most
of the operation is done with a spacebar
you step forward through the page
through with the space bar hopping over
various characters completely different
for anything you know now and I had sat
wiggling my fingers in the dark with my
eyes closed
designing it for some months and I
showed the state diagram to John post
and Mark Miller who were going to
implement it and and John said to mark
will this got some interesting ideas I
think we should fix this mark says I
know him better than you do let's do it
his way first and what I told them was
it's going to feel creamy smooth you'll
be able to edit text and it was feel
very smooth and natural and they could
see nothing in the state diary diagram
they had anything to do with this
and to this day Mark Miller is furious
because it felt creamy smooth and
natural and he doesn't know why and the
answer is because it was designed
according to a completely different
paradigm
and and it is and I live in that
paradigm and you will see my software
one day and it won't be anything like
like anything you've ever seen so the
one thing I've concentrated on well I'd
three major thrusts I worked I was
working on Texas systems from the very
beginning I put in a patent application
for for image synthesis in 1969 was late
in the game but then I realized that
what I was up against and everybody his
brother we're doing that so I dropped
out of that area and and interfaces
which which of which mine are totally
different so enough of that let me
concentrate now on the most important
stuff because there's only one concept
I've narrowed it down further there's
just one thing I have to accomplish and
maybe it will have all been worthwhile
the objective of the Xanadu project was
multifold multifarious from the
beginning and in three months of
frenetic thought in the fall of 1960 I
worked out what the design of software
should be now you may ask why it was
that I thought I could do this and the
answer is I was a if you think I'm
arrogant now you should have seen me
then and I had already when I was doing
when I was doing magazines I I worked
out how to do multicolor printing just
you know on my own and I just say this
to the printer with this work and he
said oh sure and then when he finished
putting it together I showed him how it
folded he was astounded because his oh
sure had been vacuous conversational
thing and he didn't know what I was what
I was telling him it was ID I built up a
certain confidence about how to how to
make layered effects layered effects to
me we're all was the center traveling
matte Technicolor multi gun color CRTs
at that when I when I did my eighth
grade paper run proposed method for
color television there was no such thing
although my father showed me the sets at
CBS where they were already painted and
Kelly because they expected them to be
also at that time layered sound layered
recordings were just beginning Les Paul
and Mary Ford Lewis and Beebe Barron who
did the who did the soundtrack for
forbidden
we're right around the corner from where
I lived and so I had an intimate sense
that oh boy layer defects are gonna be
the thing in the future it was very
clear how this was done being on an
analog so the notion that a final effect
whether it's an illuminated manuscript
or a Technicolor movie is the focal
result of a confluence of many different
structures merged by someone who is
thinking out the combined effect this to
me was central in the design of media my
heroes when I was a kid were when I was
12 years old my heroes were Buckminster
Fuller Orson Welles Walt Disney and
Bertrand Russell and so and the the
parallel to to the Orson Welles has been
very painful because only recently when
I've read his biography of I learned how
closely our careers have been parallel
start at the top and working way down
but the point is if Orson had known it
he would have been the greatest software
designer that ever happened because he
truly understood media who understands
media in our time is it laboratories
with that word in their name perhaps not
perhaps it is those perhaps it is those
who really understand how effects are
put together not only when Orson was 25
what had he done I believe he had
simultaneously three hits on Broadway
his own theater and he made he did a
radio repeated a radio show which was
the first and crucial experiment in mass
disinformation called the War of the
Worlds he did it wittingly because of
some very large lawsuits he always
claimed that he did not do it wittingly
but of course if you listen to the
recording he says haha this was just our
little joke at the end he knew perfectly
well what he was doing and so there he
was 25 I believe when he was 26 he went
to Hollywood did he go to film school he
became film school what was his first
project Citizen Kane that film which is
regarded as the quintessential directors
of all time he understood everything
that went into a film and so and then
for the rest of his life he went around
with his suitcases full of projects
unpacked gradually piecing together his
his movies that he was able to finish so
much is is a wonder recently his a
fellow was finally released and I was
amazed to discover that three women had
played Desdemona which is very
interesting cuz in my first film I'd had
do retakes and the heroine was played by
two different women it was a great
pleasure to me that nobody couldn't
nobody noticed mm so this is what media
are about in my opinion media are those
channels by which information packages
are created and an information package
is that which contains a point of view
now the engineers don't aren't quite
aware about this point of view business
they seem to think that that there is
point of view free information and that
somehow by waiving the right wand or
dispersing the right gaggle of agents
you can go and come back with the truth
and by dipping that by dipping written
documents in the right kind of technical
acid somehow the factoids will Clank to
the bottom of the tank they pour off the
acid and then roll out the factoids and
and put them in so in some sort of
database this is ain't so the poor every
word and sentence or almost every word
and sentence in printed work has meaning
and that meaning may not be of interest
to you but it's there and the question
is which meanings do you throw out the
great question that I asked myself at
3:00 was why all right to write or to
say anything is to destroy information
because you have to leave things out
this would infuriated me about writing
when I got older because as I learned
the techniques of writing I hated the
fact
that you were destroying that
information base of which the writing
was simply the visible part of the
iceberg every journalist has this
problem every movie editor has this
problem everybody who speaks from
electron has this problem but it's
especially painful if you're writing
from a pile of notes my big piles of
notes are over there but I've got lots
and lots of notes there's my great
problem too many no it's too much
material and I don't want it to be
thrown away I don't want to throw it all
at you but I wanted to be there for you
who want to hear more about this point I
want to be able to explore it so to
create a genre of non-destructive
writing was part of my agenda I had a
very long agenda in 1960 I wanted to I
was concerned about political freedom I
was concerned about the 1984 dangers
about about the government taking over
about the authentication of documents I
was scratching my head and thinking
would have to be something like
checksums
and and indeed that's what it's coming
out to hash code type checksums as the
as the front line of authentication the
the issues of how can academia proceed
replacing those paper media we have
known and the point is that there was
hardly anyone I could talk to and many
people thought I was insane well in fact
quite possibly I was technically insane
since the definition of paranoia is
believing what all these people did not
believe now is the time to roll the roll
the cut and paste tape because we don't
know now we never will let me talk a
little about writing the process of
writing is the process of rewriting
basically this is what you're always
taught and the words cut and paste have
always symbolized to me the quintessence
of human creativity the cut and paste
process which I will show you in this
video is cutting things up and putting
them together in a different order no
that's not what they would have you
believe at Apple and that's not what I
would have you believe at Windows and
that's what takes me off sound please
sound please
five pages five page printout of draft
six and then making draft seven I also
have a one-page illustration so this is
real writing this is what cut and paste
is really about okay you can cut this
out no thank you the the reason I say
this is I am deeply deeply angry at
whatever techno I changed the meanings
of the word cut and pasted from their
true meaning of the parallel
consideration of rearranged text on a
tabletop to the hide and plug functions
that we associate with the so called
Macintosh clipboard a clipboard which is
just like any other clipboard except you
can't see it anything you put on a
destroys what was there previously and
if you if the phone rings you lose the
contents it's like a real clipboard and
if every other way except there are no
other aspects so this garbagey vile
piece of software which is built into
the Macintosh at the floor at the
basement level has then been rebaptised
with those holy words cut and pasted now
my first job at the New York Times when
I was 17 I was a copy of 1819 a freshman
year I was a copy boy I filled the paste
putts I literally went to a great big
bucket of library paste which made from
flour and water and filled all the paste
pots and put them around the city desk
so the guys when they cut up their
articles would paste them together in
the in the regular order and that is
what rewriting is about and I do this
for three to six hours a day as you see
here because there are no software tools
that allow you to do it
none and I've been trying to build a
software tool that would allow you to do
it for 35 years and the paper I wrote
thirty years ago for the ACM conference
detailed the method by which this should
be done and we're finally and we finally
just implemented a prototype of it at
the Sapporo hyper lab and that is the
that's the tape I will show you next
could we go to the next tape please so
the problem is no okay it was obvious
that electronic media would replace
paper media the question is in what way
a lot of people take this strange point
of view that we must imitate paper in
fact I just heard someone say quite
recently someone someone of a certain
repeat
in the field that he wants to build
electronic paper
how about electronic buggy whips how
about electronic bearskin suits I mean
the what I hate about the Macintosh
after the vile so-called clipboard the
abominable hidey hole well the other
thing I hate about the Macintosh is it's
not a computer it's a paper simulator so
the so-called WYSIWYG is reducing
everything to a two-dimensional
structure because that's what the that's
what the users will feel comfortable
with we can't jar them with so we have
to use all these so-called metaphors to
make them comfortable like like the
garbage can the garbage can metaphor now
that's a really reassuring metaphor
where it means either save this or
destroy it
if you put a file into the wastebasket
to destroy it if you put a disk into the
wastebasket you're saving it so that's
that's what I call a really clear thing
no I don't believe in metaphors my the
the point is to have clear virtuality
Zhai Eakins construct logic which makes
sense consider the game of checkers is
it a metaphor you can say well those
things are called Kings never mind they
come on let's be serious
it is a set of constructs which fit
together are we up roll it okay
take two hi I'm here at the sapporo
hybrid lab showing you with regrettably
a terrible flicker i thought that we'd
be able to use the other monitor today
and of course in the last minute we're
gonna show you the zip editor we've been
working on for some months the
programmers who worked on it do not want
their names on it until it's in a more
polished shape but i want you to have
some notion of what the graphics are
about because this is different from any
other editor that has existed although
it's the design i published in 1965
holding it in today's terms we're
talking about trans parallel media
meaning things which are side by side
and explicitly connected so transparent
media includes for example captions for
a picture which point directly to parts
of the picture trans parallel media
include anything where you have explicit
connections but parallel media is where
you just see things side by side like an
article in an illustration okay so in
this context what I'm showing you now is
transparent media with transfusion only
we're leaving out links because I want
to stress the notion of transclusion as
the counterpart of links transclusion
and link are like left and right hand
link is convictions between things which
are different transclusion czar system
maintained connections between instances
which are the same in different context
ok so to me transclusion has always been
the heart of electronic media and i
think eventually people will understand
this so here we're talking about
transparent media meeting things seem
side by side where you can see the
explicit connections
no I have to work the camera to the
okay
these other things called zips and what
they do is they track the connections in
this case I'm only tracking the being a
parent look at the translucent
connections between objects so the same
paragraph is used in more than one place
that remains a line showing the
transclusion so I'm going to fire this
thing up again and you'll see in another
context what the among many uses of this
stuff example the history history is a
vast complex of stuff many which can be
divided into millions of stories
obviously we can't understand billions
of stars but there are millions of
stories and the deeper you understand
the more different stories you see and
more ways you can place the same
material in different stories okay so
the idea i've always had for historical
writing is transparent presentation of
separate stories with explicit
connection between them noted a
hypertext was a jumping off a cliff to
the end of the darkness but rather
seeing the story side by side and seeing
the explicit connections links and
transfusions between their parts so
moving right along here zip editor hello
this framework by the way the
intelligent pad system of Professor user
Tanaka which we are using for the
interface on the system the inner
routines are in tickle presently in this
very crude prototype ok
so this is the intelligent pad playing
field so let's take a very simple
historical example from my friend
Elliott Porter who is a historical
researcher in Berkeley California he's
done some very interesting researches
into the early 20th century history the
early 20th century and some very odd
facts for example the way the that
German spies were paying Irish
separatists to undermine the British
before World War one in Berkeley
California really odd stuff so I looked
over his materials and looked for some
stories that would make a nice
transparent example so he's found a
couple here for example it's a short
very short story about the life of a man
named Elaine Ireland that was condensed
for the previous version of his identity
in five paragraphs mr. Ireland was a was
a some sort of racist and colonial
ideologue and then there's another man
whom we admire walter Lippmann who was a
conservative commentator and scholar for
many years very distinguished gentleman
who won the pulitzer prize but what if
they haven't come they got a story
between at least one that i'm
Eliott Porter's Metiria there was a
think tank oops wrong thing there was a
think tank called the inquiry the
inquiry was set up during World War one
at the request of President Wilson for
essentially white papers by scholars on
potential alignments of the of the
international arena after the war and so
here's a couple paragraphs on that but
it happens that we can translate
something from Ireland story into this
and you see the transclusion is marked
and shown so we see that this is the
same paragraph and here's a paragraph
for the Lippmann story
and here's another paragraph from the
Lippmann story that can both be
translated into the same context so
walter Lippmann was the executive
secretary of the inquiry before we went
to Paris Alain Ireland worked by the
work there and Lippmann funneled
researches to mr. house who was was
Wilson's chief of staff so anyway this
is an example of how okay this is the
notion of transparent all under
comparison I talked about Rashomon and
being able to see things side by side to
me you the the Macintosh is a step back
we must take media beyond two
dimensionality we must allow the
dimensionality of the media and the
topology of the media to follow the
structure of the ideas now the thing is
that I think to a certain extent some
engineers are slightly naive about the
structure of ideas and recognizing and
rather than cutting our ideas to fit the
shape of the software such as
hierarchical directories and word
processing which I regard is an
abomination word processing just reduces
everything cornflakes and loses all
structure loses all previous connection
so every bite is like a newborn babe
rather than cut the material to fit the
existing software we should design the
space in which the media subsists to fit
the structure of the ideas and that's
why I say new topologies of writing new
topologies of media structure for
example can we have the Macintosh please
okay
that's what the one I want is this one
yeah we'll get to that one yeah
this this is my fundamental notion of
how of how a computer screen should look
you can have as many windows as you like
and whatever you like on them but you
have trans pointing arrows that cross
the boundaries of these windows no
people say but that's not how God
intended windows to be used wrong it's
this how the guys how far they got at
Xerox PARC
ok and the real point is that this is
what you need you need B to be able to
scroll this and have the arrow heads and
tails follow the connections where they
are and these can be not just narrow
arrows but they can link to whole
paragraphs whole objects now here we
have let's say scrollable text
scrollable text and some sort of
animatable risible object as this thing
rhymes as these things scroll the
pointers should continue to be attached
to those parts that are relevant so this
is what I call trance pointing trance
pointing windows and transparent sorry
about the terms but we're now unpacking
the Xanadu concept the Xanadu Xanadu
project is right now in a sort of limbo
we're trying to rescue the software that
Autodesk paid for from 92 to 98 to 88 to
92 meanwhile I'm trying to go ahead with
the same strategy so the objectives are
transparent media the objectives are and
always have been for me trance parallel
media transporting windows and
transclusion as the basis now I these
ideas may be new to you either they've
been my idea since 1960 but it gets a
little easier to explain to them because
now you're up to speed on things like
like the network publishing and plain
old vanilla links but we basically the
World Wide Web has gotten to the hyper
card stage we now have a spaghetti
hypertext where you jump off into
nothingness not know wearing knowing
where you're going because the all you
know is that there's a link in your
going somewhere this is ideally suited
to a generation that seems not to know
where it's coming from or where it's
going but we need better we need to be
able to see things side by side now you
could have a wet trance parallel web
browser meaning that here's here's the
original you hit a button you hit you
click on something and next to it
appears the next structure side by side
so this is this can be in the browser
structure what do I mean by trans
parallel
I mean that there is that there are
explicit connections connecting things
now you see these in books there are
many there are many book and and paper
based media which have transparent
connections but let's say a picture next
to a newspaper article is not
transparent because it does not it may
not specifically illustrate some
particular feature in that article so
transparent by transparent all I mean
there is an there is an actual specific
set of connections between one thing and
another
okay so transparent windows are how we
intercomparison